let's go to rachel hey there mike here
with luca doncic
luca you guys had your worst loss of the
season handed to you by the warriors
just a couple nights ago how did it feel
to bounce back with this game
oh it was great you know at the end
we almost like lost it again but you
know
we didn't have bad luck this time you
know we played till the end and i'm
really happy we got this win
you are out there dueling point for
point three-pointer for three-pointer
shot for shot with steph curry
who won his first mvp when you were just
a teenager
back in spain what was it like out there
to go back and forth with him
for me it was suffering you know every
time he shot the ball i think it was
going in it's
something unbelievable i didn't see in
my life you know he's an amazing player
he changed his game
and it's always like fun to play against
him and today
uh we gotta win but you know it's always
fun to play against him and you were
certainly going at it as well you're
just 21 years old but you've hit your
career high tonight
42 points how did it feel out there and
what were you seeing that maybe you
haven't been seeing so much earlier this
season
i mean uh i think uh you know my three
point has been horrible this season
i can't make it in the pool so that's
how we say but you know i just
uh gotta trust uh my work you know my
three
three point shot and just keep keep
working on it well in america we say uh
couldn't hit the ocean
so yeah there you go one
you guys are still going to be in 14th
in the western conference even with this
win tonight
what do you see for the team ahead to
climb back into playoff contention i
mean we just got to keep uh
playing every game like this you know on
defensive end obviously steph was
hitting everything today but you know we
got to put the effort in
it starts in the fast event and that's
what we we have to go from
thanks so much luca appreciate it and
congratulations back to you mike thank
you
all right rachel can can't make it in
the pool when he made it in the pool
here tonight in dallas as doncic man the
mavericks
improve to 10 and